we begin this morning with the arrest of
the man suspected of sending explosive
devices to high-profile critics of
President Trump the four day nationwide
manhunt came to an end Friday at a
Florida auto parts store when federal
agents arrested 56 year-old c-czar se AK
he's suspected of sending more than a
dozen pipe bombs to prominent Democrats
through the mail seoc has a criminal
history dating back to the 90s and it
includes a 2002 conviction for making a
bomb threat an active supporter of
President Trump seoc frequently lashed
out online against Democratic
politicians his arrest came on the same
day that four more suspicious packages
were discovered sent to liberal
billionaire
Tom Styer Democratic senators Cory
Booker and Kamala Harris and former
Obama administration intelligence chief
James clapper
that followed the discovery of pipe
bombs that were sent to a nearly a dozen
other Trump critics including former
President Barack Obama and former
presidential candidate Hillary Clinton
David Beck know is in Miami Miami rather
where say says our seoc is being held
David good morning
Michelle good morning the amateur
bodybuilder and former stripper is due
in federal court on Monday morning and
we will be there but I want to start
this morning by giving you a sense of an
interview we got well the woman who
manages a pizza restaurant here in South
Florida
she says that mr. seoc was a model
employee showed up on time people liked
him no worries but she says he was
anti-gay anti-black anti-jew anti just
about everything but then she added I
couldn't fire him just because I didn't
like what he believed he's a lot of
hatred he was definitely not right in
the head Deborah Greg Ian was say ox
boss at a Fort Lauderdale pizza
restaurant she says while he was an
attentive employee he often expressed
extreme political views he was real
racist he was vile
you know anti everything but I really
don't know
what who I was talking to nightly when
seoc was arrested on Friday it appeared
he was living in this white van that was
plastered with pro-trump stickers as
well as those targeting the president's
political opponents literally you can
see pictures of Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton in the crosshairs of a gun site
nearby a sign that says CNN sucks each
of them were sent pipe bombs this week
say I've posted videos of himself at
Trump rallies and then used social media
to lash out at politicians he was a
little intimidating if you weren't a
trump supporter it was his erratic
behavior and that conspicuous van that
caught the eye of mark Weiss he would
strip down to basically his underwear
and walk down the street and he would
shower right here every morning I never
saw him with anyone never never talked
to you directly
never say ox arrest came four days after
the first explosive device was found at
the home of billionaire and Democratic
donor George Soros more than a dozen
other packages containing bombs were
also mailed all of them in a manila
envelope with six stamps and a return
address of Florida congresswoman debbie
Wasserman Schultz on Thursday
investigators found one fingerprint on
one of the packages then they lifted a
DNA sample from one of the explosive
devices after matching that fingerprint
and DNA to seoc the FBI used video
surveillance near a South Florida postal
facility to identify him an electronic
device was then used to ping and track
his cell phone which led to his location
it took a little over a day from the
first fingerprint being detected to his
arrest but it's still not known if all
of those bombs that were mailed have
been found there may be other packages
in transit now and other packages on the
way so we need the help of everyone out
there every citizen everyone in law
enforcement everyone we've got to help
with this investigation in
days to come you know as scary as this
week was for a lot of people no one was
harmed by any of this in fact the FBI
says none of those devices were actually
rigged to explode so they're not sure if
say out just did a lousy job assembling
them or if he never really intended to
hurt anyone and he just wanted to
threaten people Michele and it's still
very well may not be over David Beck now
in Miami thank you